if I decide to move up here and I become
irritating or you just don't have the
same feeling you thought you had I need
to know oh I don't want to be somewhere
I've not wanted no I would tell you
right away I promise I feel better it
really does
but it's scary see right now Colton my
relationship is I don't know I don't
know where it is I don't know where it's
going mm-hmm
am I willing to leave quote behind
I don't want him to feel like I'm giving
him up deserted him after all these
years you know Colts married him and him
and Vanessa they need their space
you know but it would be nice to meet
them you know I would like them I think
it would help our our relationship and
culture my relationship if you do decide
you're going to move up here I will come
down there I'll meet Colt pack up the
house you come down there help me move
up here sure look I love you very much
dear I really do
are you really willing to take a chance
pack up everything and move up to Canada
and move in with me
okay
haha
willing to take a chance
yeah you are yes you're a hundred
percent sure you're willing to move up
here and move in with absolutely I'm 100
sure come here
[Music]
coming to Canada and basically starting
over is a very big deal yeah definitely
Tony you better be worth all that I'm
giving up of course I am
so what now
go home and celebrate
I want Tony to be my forever I am in
love for the last time of my life
but I'm still worried about cold
I don't know how he's going to react
when I tell him I'm moving in with Tony
I'm risking a lot by moving to Canada
[Music]
[Music]
thank you